China's new tariffs on American products
take effect today amid heightened
tensions over trade China announced the
tariffs on more than a hundred and
twenty items including fruits meat wine
and metal products the move is a
response to the US tariffs on aluminum
and steel CBS News senior global affairs
contributor Ian Bremmer is president of
the Eurasia group good morning one two
how much of a punch back is this they
told us this is gonna come last week it
is significant it certainly represents a
tipping point in the relationship to the
United States and China remember last
year the mar-a-lago summit was in some
ways the high point of Trump and foreign
policy a lot of people didn't expect it
this is definitely gonna get worse but
we're not at a trade war because the
Chinese we're talking three billion
dollars of goods they're hitting red
states they want to show Trump if you
keep going we're gonna hit you hard but
for now it's the Chinese taking it
seriously it's not I wouldn't say this
is seriously escalatory pork a key
product here Iowa's a state where they
produce a lot of pork in North Carolina
to swing States let me ask this though
North Korea is also happening in this
context - China's a key player in that
how does that get into the mix here with
this this trade backin especially
because Trump had been saying all the
way through that he was linking Chinese
cooperation on North Korea to trade but
now that trade is becoming more of a
priority has already said hey I'm gonna
meet with Kim jong-un myself plus the
Chinese just had that summit with Kim
didn't tell the Americans about it in
advance I would say we're not gonna be
getting as much direct support and
coordination from the Chinese on that
issue well president Trump has said
trade wars are good and but there is a
trade war the US would win
who wins if there is a trade war between
the two countries and who really
benefits
well we both lose China will lose more
our economies much larger let's keep in
mind the Trump said this on a lot of
countries in South Korea we have a new
bilateral trade deal so that were upped
got done it's beneficial to American
truckers the pharmaceutical company is
gonna be more helpful on currency Obama
didn't get that done in part it's
because Trump was willing to take the
risk and hit him and in part it's
because the United States is a hell of a
lot bigger than South Korea they don't
have a lot of choice China
would cause a lot more damage to the
United States if they wanted to really
get into it with us
but around Trump both his advisors as
well as the governor's the CEOs whether
it's Steve Jobs or it's Mark Zuckerberg
they agree that they don't have access
to China the way they want you they're
massive IP intellectual property issues
with China
so unlike the NAFTA countries where
Trump's getting a lot of internal
pushback saying hey you can say what you
want but don't actually do this because
it's gonna hurt us on China he has a lot
of people in the United States egging
him on say China is engaging in unfair
practices that's another reason why I do
believe that this relationship is gonna
deteriorate yeah so the president is
threatening now another sixty billion
dollars on tariffs of Chinese imports as
well at what point are you gonna get
nervous so when I've talked to senior
Chinese leaders they tell me that the
intellectual property issues are the
ones that they're much they're much more
concerned about than just an issue of
tariffs because they can't really fix
the IP issue right they they have
decided that these are strategic sectors
for them they have national champions
they're not a free-market economy they
don't have rule of law they're a state
capitalist authoritarian regime and
while I don't think we're heading to a
trade war I do think we're heading to a
cold war on technology where they're key
AI companies are key AI companies
actually are not interacting where we
want to buy goods from China they want
to sell them to us that's when it's a
problem all right Ian Bremmer thank you
very much